let's bring in now Ken Paxton Texas
Attorney General Mr attorney general
thanks for being here I we've been
trying to get a plan or maybe the plan
is no plan that's been the plan so far
out of the White House for what happens
after title 42 what's Texas's plan when
the floodgates open for illegals
so this was The Last Vestige of any type
of federal law that would protect us
from illegal immigration that the Biden
Administration over the last two years
whether it's stopping the building of
the wall whether it's continuing Catch
and Release whether it's the remaining
Mexico program whether it's title 42
they have announced literally on day one
that they were going to stop
deportations they have dismantled
federal law by themselves not with the
approval of Congress and so it's very
important that we just got this victory
in remain in Mexico this is our our best
hope of protecting the people of Texas
and the people of this country from
illegal immigration the consequences
that bill malusian just talked about Mr
attorney general I have to ask the Biden
Administration is ask acting like they
have a plan there is something they're
going to unveil you would think they'd
be coordinating with for example perhaps
a border state like Texas do you have
any indication of their plan if title 42
expires
you know that's been the frustrating
part about dealing with them they're
massive consequences to our state
whether you talk about the drugs that
bill malusian was referring to or just
this the massive influx of illegals and
the consequences of that we've never
been given uh information about a plan
and I I don't suspect we're going to get
one this time and I I'm very suspicious
of any so-called plan that they have not
shared with the border states obviously
it affects us on a daily basis with five
six seven thousand people a day crossing
the border
uh let me ask you this because this is a
statement from Abdullah Hassan he's the
assistant white house uh press secretary
he says to be clear
the lifting of the title 42 Public
Health order does not mean the border is
open anyone who suggests otherwise is
doing the work of Smugglers and
spreading misinformation to make a quick
Buck off of vulnerable migrants
what do you say to that
I just say look at the facts I mean
we've had over 2 million people across
the border the last fiscal year we've
had since the Biden Administration took
over the the presidency over a 300
percent increase in illegal immigration
I mean the numbers speak for themselves
so this idea that somehow title 42 going
away which we know is going to cause a
massive influx because what they're now
going to do that was our only remaining
Vestige of some type of law that that
prevented people from coming across and
claiming Asylum so now they come across
and claim Asylum that's why the Romania
Mexico is so important that's the that's
the provision law that deals with Asylum
and making people stay in their country
of origin or be detained until they get
to their hearing the by demonstration
wants to just let them all in send them
to where they're going to go and then
hope that someday they have a hearing so
Mr attorney general we know there's no
plan we know title 42 is expiring we
know you're not getting support from the
federal government let's just set that
aside that's a given but we know in an
even larger invasion is coming your your
job in the Governor's job is to
safeguard the citizens of Texas so I'd
sort of ask again like what is the new
approach Texas can take in light of this
Invasion it it's unsustainable it erases
our sovereignty are there more tools you
haven't yet used that you can do to
safeguard your state
so we've got the legal means that I just
talked about we've got we are arresting
people that are crossing illegally that
we can arrest for state law violations
uh the problem is the the plan the way
that you that she used to work is that
people would come across the board and
they were trying to hide from border
patrol they were coming across all types
of areas trying to avoid if they're
evading you know the border patrol now
because of the fight Administration they
the cartels know hey there's a deal here
just bring as many people as they want
to be found to to the yes to the border
patrol and they turn themselves in
there's that which puts us in a
difficult spot because now it's the
cartels working with border patrol not
their fault uh because if I
Administration has told them to do that
and then the Biden Administration takes
them from there so there's nowhere for
Texas to intervene this is all set up to
make it impossible for us to stop
illegal immigration it's great attorney
general I have a question for you I was
down in Texas not too long ago and one
of a local journalists there said the
real story is the ngos the real story is
the money going there the uh the shoddy
way they're hiring people within the
ngos to vet people uh she said she told
me there was just like high school kids
um that their you know recent graduates
that are now doing the job of vetting
people coming to our country and they're
doing it within 24 hours I personally
witnessed at an airport people coming
from the Dominican Republican would only
been in our country for 24 hours so
who's doing the vetting talk to me about
the ngos and the responsibility they
bear
um and their and and their role in this
entire open border policy from the bite
Administration
yeah and that's a great question these
non-governmental organizations We
Believe are participating in violating
our state and federal laws and we're
actually starting to look at that we've
already had an investigation believe it
out of our Texas State Bar Foundation
that we believe are participating in
helping people come here illegally and
not doing it the right ways and so we
started that investigation several
months ago we just stepped that up and
we're looking for information about
other non-governmental organizations
that are doing just the same so this is
just the beginning we're going to try
try that angle to see if there's a way
that we can at least inhibit some of
these these non-government entities from
doing illegal work for the federal
government or for whoever
so Mr attorney general I'd love to ask
you one follow-up to Pete's question
about the tools at your disposal and I
want to say I think I speak for all of
us when we really appreciate you coming
on and answering these questions and I
think we're all on the same side of
hoping to solve what seems to be an
impossible or maybe not impossible an
unwilling issue of the federal
government to solve and that is this a
few a few weeks ago a month ago
um you got in texts that you declared
the governor put US declaration of an
invasion uh availing new powers in his
statement for the state to deport
illegal immigrants to the Border it was
criticized by some like uh Ken
cuccinelli who said there's no point in
taking somebody to the Border you have
to take somebody across the border for
it to be effective what I would love to
ask you today is a response to that and
B have you seen any appreciable effect
after you declared that invasion in
helping this crisis
yeah and it goes back to the the
challenge that I talked about most of
the people are not trying to evade
border patrol they're going directly to
border patrol so the idea of declaring
an evasion is is it's it's a fact I mean
it is an invasion and it should give us
the authority to do more we have two
challenges one the fact that they're
bringing people to the Border but
they're bringing to border patrol which
takes us out of the equation and second
we still have this Supreme Court
decision Arizona V U.S that was decided
under the Obama Administration that said
the federal government had complete
control over the Border we need to
challenge that and so we're looking for
angles where some one of our state
government officials whether it's the
legislature whether it's the governor
violates that we get sued and then we
can take it back up and say hey that
decision can't be right it cannot be
right that the federal government can
have its own laws avoid enforcing them
and then say that the states can't
protect themselves by availing
themselves of those same laws that
doesn't make any sense because otherwise
federal government just passes laws and
there's no there's really no consequence
other than to say now the states can't
protect themselves that cannot be the
right uh outcome so actively looking for
that constitutional challenge yep all
right Attorney General of Texas Ken
Paxton thank you very much for coming on
sir we appreciate it thank you Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas to you I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis